logan is with us in Texas hey Logan how
are you I'm good Dave how are you today
better than I deserve what's up well I
we just kind of realized oh probably
about a month and a half ago that we had
been doing Dave ish for too long and
kind of gotten gung-ho and finally got
gizelle intense and in doing so I'll
kind of secret advice of my dad and
father-in-law it was actually a pastor
as well and wanted to kind of get your
intake on an input on something that
they told me about a truck that I have
the trucks is a 2008 Toyota Tundra that
is I think we owe right now right at
19,000 on it I think that it Kelley Blue
Book's for private sell right at 17 it
is not the next step in our baby step
but I'm just trying to decide what I
need to do if I need to sell it or try
to just hold on to it cuz you're a
reliable truck
what's your household income it's
currently 63,000 in May in May it will
go up to 73,000 and what's the other car
that you have worth the other car is
probably worth $1,000 it's our houki
okay and you have any other vehicles no
sir
okay and how much a debt do you have not
counting your house total you have 19 on
the truck and what else yeah that's
right
unfortunately right now it's totaling
right at about a hundred that's seven
thousand in student loan debt the truck
we I have a mower that I financed to
start a mowing business thinking that
was going to be a good plan that'd be a
video right there yeah well go on the
mower and 32-hundred your mower is nicer
than your second car yes
yes you are you are correct are you a
are you using it are you making any
money with it I actually was on my way
right now to go to go and do a couple
extra mowings before before that so what
are you making a year worth of mower so
I only did it I started this year with
it and so what you're making Union I
made it I'm making probably about fifty
five hundred dollars you use it much I
didn't know that's right okay you need
to sell it okay cuz you're not using it
yes okay and so that gets rid of that
debt now the the rule of thumb I use on
vehicles is if all of your vehicles
added together equals more than half
your annual income then you've got too
much tied up in things that go down in
value you're close but you're not there
especially with your raise coming up the
second rule of thumb I use is can you be
debt-free
within two years except your home if you
live on a beans and rice rice and beans
budget and and if not is the car the
reason and this one's on the bubble the
trucks on the bubble then yet they're
okay so can you pay off fifty thousand
dollars making the kind of money you're
making a year for two years that's beans
and rice and that's picking up some kind
of extra job right yes sir and I
actually have my my real estate license
and so I'm currently tied up in another
schooling for my full-time job and so as
soon as that frees up my time then I
will all be getting back into real
estate I mean that's but you're not bad
hustle well after your raise you're
supposed to be making how much again and
right at 73 yeah
paying off fifty a year out of that's
not going to work no sir so if the truck
allows you to do that I might sell the
truck or if you gave if you you know if
you can make twenty thirty thousand to
in real estate a year apart
which you probably can do if you hustle
all right then the truck might be a
keeper it's borderline but uh the bottom
line is we got rid of the truck you
could be out of debt in two years yes
sir
that changes the formula to thirty five
thousand or thirty or I'm sorry forty
thousand a year rather than fifty
thousand a year yes sir so it's yeah
it's more doable then and and it's it's
not a crazy it's not like if the truck
was twenty thousand I would I mean if
the truck was forty thirty thousand I
just instantly say sell it in this
scenario because it'd be too high
percentage of your income and it'd be
the problem with your situation but the
problem with your situation is you just
hadn't got started good on it yet and so
I'm gonna keep it for right now and I'm
gonna attack into this and if you look
up and realize it's the blocker then you
can cut it loose later